[Musica]
quanti fra voi alla domanda che cosa
farai da grande non ha una risposta
alzate la mano ok
bene allora il mio primo pensiero di
oggi va a chi la mano non l'ha alzata e
sono felice per voi perché almeno voi
pensate pensate di sapere che cosa
farete da grandi mentre per tutti gli
altri state tranquilli perché siete in
ottima e abbondante compagnia vi siete
mai chiesti durante il vostro percorso
di studi anche cosa mi serve questa o
quella materia e me lo stai chiedendo
uno che alle superiori ha fatto
dattilografia avete presente la sublime
arte di imparare a scrivere a macchina
esiste qualcosa di apparentemente più
inutile se esiste la stenografia e io ho
studiato anche quella quindi da questo
punto di vista ho fatto l'en plein
oppure avete mai pensato che cosa mi può
servire questa o quella esperienza anche
il corso di taglio cucito che ho fatto
alle medie io non ho fatto il corso di
taglio e cucito ma magari qualcuno qui
dentro si beh oggi sono qui per dirvi
che in realtà tutte le esperienze che
avete fatto che farete
alla fine vi serviranno per raggiungere
il vostro vero obiettivo l'unica cosa
che conta davvero è quella di sapersi
destreggiare tra paura e passione
oggi su questo palco non sarò da solo
perché avrò un ospite graditissimo e lo
chiamo qui sul palco vicino a me
abbiamo azel
[Applauso]
e insieme a lui e alla sua musica vi
mostrerò come tutto ciò sia possibile
la mia è stata la tipica infanzia degli
anni 70 nel nord est papa imprenditore
mamma casalinga un fratello due sorelle
ed è difficile da credere oggi qui su
questo palco ma sono stato un bambino
estremamente timido poche parole e tanta
tanta paura di esporsi
[Musica]
mi scrivono scuola elementare e lungo la
strada incontro la mia prima vera grande
passione state attenti perché una
passione davvero originale
scopro infatti il calcio sono pur sempre
gli anni ottanta e l'offerta formativa
per i bambini non è poi così ampia ma
come il 99 per cento di bambini della
mia età mi vedo già pronto a calcare i
campi di serie a
[Musica]
voglio essere sincero con voi oggi non
sono un granché a giocare ma mi piace un
sacco mi diverto e deciso di proseguire
la mia carriera di calciatore anche alle
scuole medie alle scuole medie però
incontra una persona davvero importante
un professore illuminato perché ce ne
sono ancora ce ne sono ancora tanti
anche qua dentro
chi mi fa scoprire la bellezza del
teatro per la prima volta
salgo su un palcoscenico e sono
intimamente convinto di aver scoperto la
mia strada
quindi se dovessi riassumere la mia
infanzia la potrà rappresentare più o
meno così
[Musica]
finisco le scuole medie e per la prima
volta in vita mia devo capire chi o che
cosa sarò da grande e dopo uno
stakanovista veneto penso che cambierà a
che fare con i soldi potrebbe essere una
buona idea
e allora parto verso la ricerca del
santo graal parto alla volta della
ricerca del lavoro sicuro che nei miei
piani
passa attraverso l'iscrizione l'istituto
tecnico per ragionieri in terza entrano
le materie di indirizzo e mi accorgo che
forse ho fatto un piccolo errore di
calcolo perché non riesco a mettere un
bilancio in pareggio
nemmeno se mi pagano questo per un
ragioniere potrebbe essere un problema
comunque stringo i denti
vado avanti mi diplomo perché ho deciso
che mi riscatterà con la scelta
universitaria
ho deciso adesso che da grande diventerà
uno psicologo
così magari capirò che cosa mi è passato
per la testa il giorno in cui ho deciso
di iscrivermi a ragioneria
[Musica]
indovinate un po arriva a metà del
percorso ed iniziò a bucare
clamorosamente le sessioni d'esame lo so
però c'è un aspetto positivo perché
durante quelle sessioni bucate riscopro
il vecchio amore la vecchia passione che
avevo scoperto le scuole medie e scopro
il palcoscenico non più solo attraverso
il teatro ma anche attraverso la danza e
io so che questa era la strada giusta ma
la paura che ritorna inesorabile la
paura di vivere svolgendo una
professione artistica che la maggior
parte della gente non considera nemmeno
un lavoro
ecco quella paura li è l'ostacolo più
grande e quindi non tra poche difficoltà
devo dire riesco comunque a laurearmi e
dopo la laurea
la svolta deciso di partecipare quasi
per caso ad un'audizione per selezionare
un team di street dance professionisti
che devono rappresentare un noto marchio
di abbigliamento e ancora oggi non ho
capito come come sia successo ma entro a
far parte di questo team con il quale
iniziò le prime tournée in giro per
l'italia e le prime esperienze
televisive per la prima volta seguo la
mia passione e mi sento libero creativo
e felice deciso di far evolvere quella
che ormai è diventata a tutti gli
effetti la mia professione ed insieme al
mio primo insegnante di danza fondo
quella che ad oggi è una delle più
importanti agenzie d'italia nella
creazione di eventi legati al mondo
della street dance i dubbi che avevo
all'inizio del percorso ci sono sempre
mi fanno sempre compagnia ma il fatto di
poter fare della mia passione il mio
lavoro è un'esperienza
che davvero non ha prezzo e a proposito
di esperienze che non hanno prezzo
il 24 novembre 2012 quasi sette anni fa
alle ore 7 29 della sera nasce mio
figlio eppure niente come diventare
genitore ti porta il bivio tra paura e
passione
la paura di non essere assolutamente
pronto per quel ruolo e dopo sette anni
di posso dire che pronti pronti non lo
si è mai e la passione di potersi
tuffare avviene in questa nuova
avventura ma avrò finalmente la
possibilità insieme alla mia compagna di
poter insegnare ad ettore che tutto
nella vita è possibile se ascolti un
pochino meno le tue paure e ti affidi un
pochino di più la tua passione
se gli servirà del tempo per capirlo
questo non sarà un problema perché anche
miles davis una volta ha detto alle
volte ti serve del tempo per imparare ad
essere te stesso e se servirà del tempo
anche a voi soprattutto quelli che hanno
alzato la mano non vi preoccupate perché
quella paura li la paura che provate di
fronte ad ogni video di fronte ad ogni
scelta quella paura li è normale anche
perché è l'altra faccia della paura
quella che è davvero interessante
altra faccia della paura è il coraggio e
il coraggio di andare avanti nonostante
tutto nonostante le scelte giuste o
sbagliate
nonostante i successi ei fallimenti
questa è stata la mia storia
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
ok adesso non so se mi diranno ancora
perché questa è stata la mia storia ma
adesso mi piacerebbe provare a
rappresentare la vostra storia
ok quindi provare a fare il vostro
viaggio all'interno di una settimana
tipo ma per fare questo ho bisogno
ovviamente della collaborazione di hazel
e ho bisogno soprattutto della vostra
collaborazione
quindi vi invito cortesemente ad alzarvi
tutti ieri
ok ci siamo come va bene
volete riscaldarvi un attimo shakerate
un po ok perfetto allora proviamo
insieme il viaggio all'interno di una
settimana tipo
ok la settimana al tipo comincia con il
lunedì alle 8
fatemi la faccia del lunedì alle 8
quanta tristezza
perfetto allora il lunedì alle 8
io me lo visualizzo un po così portiamo
tutti le mani alla testa tipo perché
comincia un'altra settimana
ok e vacua butto giù e 1 rimbalzo con il
corpo facile facile ok pronti 5 6 7 8
abbiamo ancora cinque sei sette ancora
una volta sai
ok perfetto mi raccomando è fondamentale
la faccia è cioè non fate
è il lunedì alle 8 quindi sarà una roba
tipo no per ora come situazione
diametralmente opposta
proviamo il sabato alle 2 del pomeriggio
quando siamo pronti a cavalcare l'onda
di un meraviglioso weekend
io me lo sono immaginato più o meno così
ai 12 34 e fondamentali picchiare forte
a terra 5 ancora 5 ancora 56 ok ok ci
siamo tutti quindi adesso mettiamo
insieme i lunedì alle 8 e il sabato alle
siete pronti 567 via 13 23 ancora ok ok
per cento bravissimi siete super bravi
ci facciamo un applauso già adesso
ok adesso prendiamo una situazione
intermedia e mercoledì sono le 8 di
mattina e voi sapete già che appena
entrerete in classe il prof interrogherà
ma no c'è un happy ending attenzione ma
inizia l'ora e il prof si dimentica
completamente della vostra esistenza si
dimentica di voi e non vi chiamo più io
me lo visualizzo così proprio piano
insieme ai 1234567 le immaginate un po
ce l'ho fatta e festeggio ok ok
dovremo solo questa sequenza 56 sundek
[Musica]
ancora e ancora
ancora una buca e ok perfetto
adesso mettiamo insieme vedo delle facce
preoccupatissime mettiamo insieme tutta
la settimana quindi lunedì sabato
mercoledì primo piano una volta ok ci
siete andiamo 567
[Musica]
ancora una l'ultima al massimo della
potenza
vabbè
[Musica]
[Applauso]